how does it feel and how does she look
in it still doesn't feel like it's mine
no no I genuinely feel like something we
need it back now okay thanks it was nice
to hold for a moment okay we loaned you
this thank you for that thanks for the
loan um do carry really say to you do
not propose when you go up you say Jenna
protein if you do that I'll punch you
cleaning them out oh did you think about
proposing at all no boy what happened
was it just out I kind of turned her and
I think she went no I'll punch her in
the mouth
what did you think of the proposal
tonight it was so fitting of a big any
birthday of a big round seventy of
number I thought it filled the room with
love and also and did it work was
touched yes it worked what if it did not
please everyone what was the plan if you
didn't win well you knew it the Netflix
party that's the whole thing he wouldn't
tell us what he was gonna do he wouldn't
give it up but he had something
obviously of course he did something but
you know what he's won 14 Emmy so he was
shut up yes 14 Emmys is that a rat coat
it's not a record but he's pretty damn
good I don't know I think it's somebody
like with 20 to go Glee here's what I
want to know yes you said earlier
tonight huh did you know and we were Liz
I was listening and caring she said no
matter who wins you know I don't win
yeah Matthew but I'm okay with it we'll
be okay okay yeah but really when you
get home yes and every day she has to
walk by your Emmy yeah how's that gonna
go how's it gonna play I think it's
gonna be fine because it'll probably be
right next to a Golden Globe ah I soaked
it'll be fine this balances things out
at home I think so
will you miss this show I mean people
really fell in love with it but you guys
said a hard fast day and said we're out
yes and I think wisely so I think this
is you know six seasons you know before
during the towel-dry you know then I
think a great luxury for writers to know
the arc that they gave I - and I'll miss
it enormous ly the depth and the
complexity of these characters were rare
but is it crazy that you guys had this
show on all of a sudden we're talking
about Russian spies and the Russians
involved in our government again season
one Jonas said to me what do you think
Russian interest in the United States is
still relevant and I went well I don't
know but maybe it's just a show about
relationships season two and three
yes it is yes it's real I told you it
was it is real were you heading with
this baby tonight I think we're heading
to the Governor's Ball for a very very
cold drink oh go enjoy your drink
congratulations very much it's a great
show thank you we'll miss the show but
at least you have something to take with
you
a memento here it is
[Music]
[Applause]